foreign
drop everything now oh it's gonna be
just my friends everywhere on tour from
Keith Urban and Nicole Kidman Fanning
out to Phoebe Bridgers getting cozy with
the potential Boo and Jennifer Lawrence
bonding with some swifties a lot went
down during Taylor Swift's era's tour
stop in Philly Sunday night I mean my
friends are so different they're they're
in different professions different Vibes
some of them are louder than others all
these different kind of personalities
but the thing that they all have in
common is sincerity I'm a huge fan well
Keith Urban and Nicole Kidman were
genuinely giving nothing but have fun
and dance tonight vibes and this Tick
Tock Keith posted check out the power
couple rocking out to Taylor's 1989 hit
style the country started captioning it
quote we had the best night
[Applause]
Keith shouts Tay Out for putting on a
phenomenal show that was good it was
very good and the swifties who showered
him and Nicole with so many friendship
bracelets which he later showed off on
his Instagram they're sort of like a
unspoken code that we're there for each
other and this Alliance that that is the
best kind of friendship you can have
well as Keith was in his own world
jamming out to Taylor with Nicole he
seemed to annoyingly capture a smooch
between rumored couple Phoebe Bridgers
and Bo Burnham happening behind him oh
my gosh yeah seemingly giving fans
confirmation that something's going on
after the two spark romance rumors
months ago very nerve-wracking yeah also
part of the VIP crew Jennifer Lawrence
the actress hanging out in the same tent
as Keith and Nicole giving a heart to
fans and receiving tons of Love Back in
the form of friendship bracelets just
like Nicole and Keith I don't understand
how you cannot fan girl about that it
made it a really good day
foreign